[Music]  the definition of icon may fluctuate  through the ages but there are some  undeniably special characters who are  iconic and I can't think of anyone who  embodies that more then my dear friend  Minerva Maus a love affair with Disney  but more specifically many it's  something that has been a thread through  my entire life whether we nozzle noses  in Anaheim or on the road in Orlando or  across the world in Paris or Tokyo it's  always so comforting to see her face  some of my favorite moments are  introducing many to my friends my  colleagues and my nieces who are sitting  here today with eyes as big as Minnie's  polka dot seeing many is like returning  home it is a special skill to bring joy  to so many and she does it with an  effortless bat of a lash don't you girl  I'm delighted to honor Minnie and her  magic with hers everyone Minnie Mouse  [Applause]  [Music]  oh thank you everyone thank you so much  [Music]  you